in Gran Torino I didn't think those were
the best Mong people they could have
chosen for that bro it was like they
were reading off a q cards yeah but they
stood for something you know different
but it was that's the whole point it's
like if it stands for something versus
just like was this like an incredibly
Stellar performance right yeah
definitely wasn't is what I'm hearing
I'll say it cuz you
[Laughter]
[Music]
won't so huge Scandal right now biggest
Scandal on Earth probably you guys saw
the Oscar nominations no people still
watch the Oscars people watch the Oscars
it still has a global audience okay it's
Talk of the Town especially this town
Maro Robbie was not nominated for Barbie
however and and Greta Gerwig who
directed it not nominated for best
director but Ryan Goins was
nominated for what you figure that one
out what what category for Ken oh but
was it like what best actor best actor
wow I didn't even think Barbie would be
like a Oscar type film it just seemed
like like a kid's Nostalgia film it got
nominated for best picture wow I didn't
did you guys watch it I didn't okay I
didn't watch it we watched it we debated
it in this room oh that's right I got to
watch it I watch Oppenheimer cuz I'm a
real film
buff yeah you're a real you're and they
won film I had an option between
Oppenheimer and Barbie and said as a
real filmmaker I'm going to go
Oppenheimer cuz I'm not going to
watch yeah I mean like it's one of those
like where you sit no didn't they make a
new category for movies like that like
where it was like a cultural phenomenon
type stuff because there are a lot of
movies that aren't considered like
cinematography so they expanded the
category so it used to be five films are
nominated now it's like nine or whatever
no I'm saying there's like a whole other
category that was made for like I heard
going to do like best comedy too cuz
comedies always get kind of like robbed
cuz there's not really it's like
dramatic so they don't yeah yeah those
those categories especially because like
a lot of those things happen on like
Netflix and stuff now so I think they
like made new categories specifically to
to preserve like The Prestige of like
best picture so it's not just like what
gross the most or whatever but then
still like you get an achievement cuz if
you did gross more like 10x more than
the quote unquote best picture there's
something to say about that too
everything you just said fake it's not
real they need to have a blockbuster one
special achievement Academy Award or
whatever the [__] what the [__] is that
that's like the special achievements is
like what they give to the old
guy special achievement the old guy it
sounds like a participation award which
one what's that one outstanding
achievement in popular film stuff like
that you know you're not going to
televise that
[__] I mean I think well okay maybe
maybe I'm also like uh I just watched
the golden Globes and they definely did
that there proposed it was proposed but
it's not an actual category yet to be
presented annually and it was announced
as a new category August 2018 oh wow but
then apparently the following month they
said they were not going to be
presenting retracted Awards they
postponed it are are are people upset
that Ryan goling won and like Margo
Robbie didn't oh he got he was nominated
they think it's like a sexist thing
because Greta Gerwig directed and she
was not included in Best Director
category and in addition to that Ryan
gokin got nominated but then Margo
Robbie didn't for for the people like as
someone who's seen it does that look
weird it tracks to me because he was
like really good in the movie and like
like I thought I thought Mar Robbie did
a fine job but it wasn't like every
everybody who walked out of the movie
with me we're all talking about Ken the
whole time okay okay okay he was just
delightful so there really is a standout
performance that Ryan
go who are the
other of all the that's the the funny
thing to me is that like like Hollywood
right now I'm surprised that they would
nominate a straight white guy like it's
the opposite so it's it there they would
have nominated a transgender like black
person or something right like that
that's probably what they would have
done but then the fact that they they
said that Ryan goling got the nomination
is it I don't know I don't think that
it's like well I mean he might just
cover that category for that there's
going to be a bunch of other nominees
and stuff like that so maybe like he
covered the category yeah he black lesbi
in that category for sure but he really
was like cuz I haven't seen it so I
don't know he was dope he was do for
sure he was Margot is great and
obviously the whole movie revolves
around her but like the way he played
Ken in such a unique machismo but also
demasculate but also evil but also like
cuz you know like the nominations seem
to go for people that are acting Beyond
something they normally do or they're
like having to really like get outside
themselves like a different take on the
role too to me it was like watching
Christian Bale and Batman where like
he's really good and really solid but
Heath Ledger just was like what everyone
was talking about exactly okay that's a
really good example and like when you're
sometimes when you're the lead character
too you don't get to do as much as the
side character sure that's like lead CIO
in every movie he's ever been even in
Black including killers of the flower
Moon by the way really even in black
panther I thought that um yes
the mord his character was able to
sometimes when you're a villain you're
allowed to have more range because you
have so much of this like self-conflict
and also affect the audience more too
and also you're not a villain in real
life so you're like doing something that
is unique from your own character you're
also not on camera the whole time so it
doesn't get annoying if you're being
that much like the whole time I could
see that okay times number twos become
the number ones yeah that happens a lot
like Keith Ledger won yeah do you think
that um Greta Gerwig should have been
nominated for best director based on how
the movie was it's tough because I don't
I didn't watch any other [__] movies
that were nominated so I can't just say
yes can you find out what I think it
depends on what other directors they're
up against in what movies also how many
other people watched all these other
films so that way where they had you
know a reasonable opinion the people
that are crying about it they watch
everything also it also seems like if if
let's say you had five nominees and they
were all women right and it's like super
cool that they're all women but they're
also five mainstream movies wouldn't
people just start complaining that some
of the Independents didn't get included
yeah so this is basic like it's still a
mainstream film yeah this is basically
the same list as the Golden Globes um so
Academy of a fall killers of the flower
Moon by Mar SC poor things Oppenheimer
the zone of interest and obviously
Barbie is isn't here Barb was nominated
golden glob and this used to be like
like I said like best picture used to be
a tip five like this but they expanded
it because of popular movies like when
the Dark Knight didn't get anything
everyone was like are you [__]
kidding me The Dark Knight was sick and
it was like the biggest movie of the
year dark was insane so then they added
this category the next year or they
added this addition next year to expand
the best picture to include popular
culture films yeah it's so weird because
also at the same time everyone looks
back at past lists and past winners and
they always point out that wasn't the
cultural Zeitgeist of that era like
these movies are so forgettable who's
watched this the second time and yeah
that does happen so it shouldn't be that
big of a letdown if something was like
snubbed you know it's like well there's
still great movies that don't get
nominated all the time yeah and 10
movies this year were nominated for best
picture so you have a tight five for
best director and then yeah you know how
many great movies coresi made but he
never won [__] yeah I know dude it's
crazy and I feel like sometimes people
like remember those things too and
they're like okay well this person
finally like deserves something so maybe
we'll give it to them I mean look how
long it took Leo to win something oh
dude ages and it also is a better at
least in my mind which maybe biased I
think it's a better accomplishment when
someone is using less resources to get
an amazing movie done versus cats that
had all the [__] money in the world
and they tanked it yeah then it's like
oh you threw all this money at the
problem couldn't fix it like they threw
tayor Swift at the problem and couldn't
fix it and they couldn't make money
that's a lot that [__] and James Cordon
the freaking darling of the C oh yeah
did anybody else watch of the flower
moon no didn't is it really good it's
good it's 3 and 1 half hours but it's
pretty damn good but the funny thing is
I'm watching it with n right and uh this
is right after golden glowes because he
got nominated for every [__] thing as
well and even the uh the lady um won
best uh female actor in that movie the
first Native American to right yeah and
she's like solid but I definitely
remember watching and being like she's
not an actress is this best like actress
you know what I mean it's like or is it
is it like the novelty of like
representing you know the first Native
American you know there there's clearly
that as well and sounds like it was a
great performance it was solid I me
she's sick half the movie dude she's
just like but that is that is a big
leverage in why certain things are not
which I think is fine I just think it
needs to be like understood across the
board that you know what I mean there is
a political yeah fine is the best
sometimes sometimes fine is is the best
in Grant Torino I didn't think those
were the best Mong people they could
have chosen for that but bro it was like
they were reading off a q cards yeah but
they stood for something you know
different but it wasn't that's the whole
point it's like if it stands for
something versus just like was this like
an incredibly Stellar performance right
yeah definitely wasn't is what I'm
hearing I'll say it cuz you
won't yeah he he'll translate for you
yeah I didn't see it I I have something
yeah to admit I I lied to you guys I'm
not a big film buff
yeah you said you don't watch films a
second time I when I when I went to go
watch Barbie it was sold out so
Oppenheimer was available so I ended up
watching Oppenheimer instead and it was
a very long movie and half of the time
um I was just annoyed at how [__]
long it was it's cuz so much dialogue
right that's the irony it's like for
Christopher Nolan in my personal very
non objective opinion [__] for sure
not his best but that's what he'll get
like best director and best like motion
picture for at like B Globes but you're
like what like Interstellar was like
[__] five times better than this
minimum but I get it Oppenheimer has a
cultural like telling a story of one of
the most important moments in like human
I did geek out when Einstein came
through though did you like that [__]
well I I also think that if you if you
read about Oppenheimer and if you read
about like this era then you become a
little bit more geeky about it so
there's context right but I understand
that in the movie like they had to build
the context part of it too for for fresh
eyes but even with that I think a lot of
people wouldn't like it but even though
it was really really good dialogue and I
still lowkey fell asleep for like a
couple minutes and Oppenheimer but even
with Barbie I definitely was like I
don't want to watch this NE want to
watch it I'm sitting there I'm like damn
it's pretty [__] good the whole time
but is it is it because you win in it
with really low expectations that you're
like huh not bad I think it's possible
that that can affect it but I'm not very
like a a big expectations person I think
I do a pretty good job moderating I
didn't watch Oppenheimer in the first 3
months you know what I mean I waited for
everything to simmer down I was like
okay cool now I have time to watch it
and it's not sold out I was pissed
because when they announced the cast for
Oppenheimer they they got that guy who
looks like Albert Einstein but you guys
know that Paul gamman like does a
perfect Albert Einstein does he yeah and
why didn't they get Paul gmar to do it
maybe it might have been too funny I
don't think so cuz he do a really
serious and good one here in the Verizon
commercials Einstein my network has G
you tried to sa the luck on it I got
what I paid for not so smart oh that
would have been so good there's a smar
way to say yeah that would have been
really good told you buddy was ice in a
Verizon
commercial L
money I think the bike's probably
[Music]
faster